ha yes now we can create better Virtual
Worlds movies avatars for video
conferencing you name it why because the
new version of blender the popular 3D
modeling program 4.0 is now here and it
can now do so much more and you will see
today that it is one completely free for
all of us and two over the years it has
become an absolute power Power House
dear fellow Scholars this is 2minute
papers with Dr car well first have a
look at the quality of movies that you
can create with this system these are
eye poly beautiful scenes all done with
a free tool available right now for all
of us what a time to be alive so what's
new well first it now has smarter
geometry nodes what is that well this
enable us to create new 3D objects where
we don't really sculp them but instead
build them with logical patterns if you
will now geometry nodes have existed in
blender before but now they are smarter
and can create more interesting patterns
and now they can become incredibly
detailed now get this the crevices of
this surface are created from random
numbers all this beautiful stuff is
built up from noise you have to try it
it's real good also a better system for
managing the bones of these virtual
characters is now available and thus we
can create more realistic and natural
deformations for these characters they
also added a better principled bsdf
model this is a mega material model if
you will where we can create diffused
surfaces Metals translucent objects
light refraction and whatever you can
possibly wish for the new version is now
more physically accurate and there was a
velvet material that is now so much more
useful it has been renamed to Sheen but
that's not the point the point is that
you can now use this beautiful
microfiber shading model and assign it
to an object that is not a piece of
cloth but a digital camera instead and
and model how tiny pieces of dust sit on
the object does that make a huge
difference oh boy look at the difference
loving it and just think about it a free
tool enables you to model virtual 3D
objects down to the level of specks of
dust and make them come to life the
sheen node can create a huge variety of
objects look at how sterile this looks
and now how much Clothier it is as light
gets scattered more around the edges of
the object so good so tasty also you can
now add a nice layer of coat to your
materials creating an even more
realistic scene and it gets better there
is a new hair shading model which takes
a bit longer you can see from the noise
here but it is way better than the
previous one it is definitely worth
waiting a bit more for this new one to
finish and now one of my favorites light
linking we have a scene here where the
lighting is Chef skiss but there is a
problem what is the problem
unfortunately that light creates a
strong specular reflection in the eyes
here we want that gone however if we
disable that light source the entire
effect of that light is gone we don't
want that and thus blender 4.0 now
supports adjusting which lights should
influence which objects that is huge you
see to be able to create your artistic
Vision sometimes physics is in the way
sometimes you need to make decisions
that are impossible in physics for
instance asking a light source to not
have an effect on a set of objects and
now we can choose which objects should
cast shadows and from which lights or if
they should be receiving light at all
this is now possible so why is this huge
there is one more reason you see
approximately
750 episodes ago we talked about an
incredible light transport simulation
technique where we could do the
impossible and that is to bend the laws
of physics yes you could recreate these
Inc incredible photorealistic
simulations and pretend as if physics
worked differently to serve your
artistic Vision better this is literally
bending physics to your will so good
these beautiful refracted costic
patterns which are not only everyone's
favorite but with this paper they could
be reorganized so much so that they can
even form an object on the wall that you
wish and hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars because it even worked for
animation if you are one of the OG
fellow Scholars who was around at this
episode I tip my papers to you make sure
to leave a comment and today some of
these concepts are making their way into
products that all of us can use for free
I love to see it obviously this is not
as advanced as this paper was but steps
are being taken in this direction and
who knows perhaps one day this paper
will end up in blender too I'd love to
see that but we are not done yet not
even close glossy surfaces are also now
rendered more realistically my favorite
here is this part once again the papers
coming alive in the hands of millions
and millions of users all around the
world so cool come profiles have also
been improved standard used to be the
default one and then filmic came which
supported a much higher dynamic range
look bright areas became much more
natural less blown out and now even
filmic has been replaced by a new color
profile called agx which looks a bit
more natural a bit more like what a real
high-end camera would create and there
is so much more it is an unbelievable
release and don't forget all this is
free free free for all of us forever you
can download it and play with it right
now it is one of the best open-source
projects ever the link to it is
available in the video description and
don't forget it has a bunch of demo
showcase files so you don't have to
start from a small cube and create
everything from scratch look there is so
much to explore I will also recommend
that you check out blend swap for more
free project files and of course my
friend Andrew price the king of donuts
also known as blender Guru he has
legendary tutorials on how to make the
tastiest dut the world has ever seen it
is aimed at complete beginners and is
now updated to blender 4.0 as fresh as
it gets check it out experiment tracking
model evaluation and production
monitoring for your deep learning
projects and llm apps this is what
weights and biases does and it is the
best everyone is using it try it out now
at
wbme SLP papers or click the link in the
description below